everything the biden administration
touches turns to ash this is true across
the board foreign policy immigration
jobs education the list goes on and on
but nowhere is it more apparent than
inflation
inflation for the past months has
already been at 40-year highs
everything is more expensive much more
expensive since joe biden took office
and according to the white house the
situation is only getting worse
so because of the actions we've taken to
address uh putin the putin price hike we
are in a better place than we were last
month um but we expect march cpa cpi
headline inflation to be extraordinarily
elevated due to putin's price hike and
we expect a large difference between
core and headline inflation reflecting
the global disruptions in energy and
food markets so chlorine inflation
doesn't include energy and food prices
headline inflation does and of course we
know that core inflation you know energy
the impact of energy of course on oil
prices gas prices we expect that to
continue to reflect what we've seen uh
the increases be over the course of this
invasion and just as an example since
president putin's military buildup
accelerated in january average gas
prices are up more than 80 cents most of
the increase in
occurred in the month of march and at
times gas prices were more than a dollar
above pre-invasion level so that roughly
25 increase in gas prices will drive
tomorrow's inflation reading and
certainly it's not a surprise to us but
we certainly think it will be reflected
you know it's bad when the white house
is trying to manage expectations like
this you know it's bad when the white
house is saying well yes we we expect
the number to be
uh not just elevated but
extraordinarily elevated but hey that's
only because gas and food is super
expensive
oh good okay good that makes me feel
better only because the the basics that
i need to live are extremely expensive
now and we're getting much much more
expensive long before putin never
invaded ukraine by the way
that's okay that's the only reason why
my money is worth much less today than
it was a year ago
this was always going to happen biden is
going to do everything he can to blame
it on big bad putin or the big bad oil
companies or the big bad supermarkets or
anybody but himself but this was always
going to happen and in some ways it's
extraordinarily simple this was going to
happen because this is the logical
inevitable consequence of the politics
of fantasy
this was the inevitable consequence of
just printing endless money
you need you need more money people are
feeling the pinch well just give them
money this was the inevitable
consequence of locking down the country
for two years and having everyone sit at
home and just hoping that everything
remains the same this was the inevitable
consequence of upending every social
institution of all of the radicalism up
to and including saying that men can
become women in the fantasy world
we're all going to live on big rock
candy mountain and everything's going to
be great in reality
everything gets worse when you live in
fantasy i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
how dare you
who says joe biden's language translator
must be thinking this is above my pay
grade that's absolutely true but do you
know what's not above your pay grade
wonderful home security which is why you
got to check out ring right now go to
ring.com
knowles you know i love ring if you want
to feel just as safe and secure as i do
as sweet little elisa does then you need
to go check out ring you know about the
video doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is on your doorstep
wherever you are in the world whether
you're in the home or outside the home
you even probably know at this point
about rings award-winning alarm but
here's my question for you have you gone
pro
are you a pro yet i don't know that you
have well you've got to go pro because
ring alarm pro is a whole home security
system not just for the
doors and the windows and the outside
and the inside but for your digital
world as well ring alarm pro protects
your devices
it's it's all the cameras and the
doodads and the gadgets for the physical
security but also a wi-fi router because
we live an increasing part of our lives
online so if you're going to protect
your life and your family and your
property you got to protect it online as
well with a ring protect pro
subscription which is an amazing deal by
the way
you can get professional monitoring for
the ultimate peace of mind
with this professional monitoring they
will call and can request emergency
services it's amazing
go check it out today go get ring go get
the award-winning ring alarm and go pro
don't mess around anymore do the
responsible thing for your family go to
ring.com knowles that is
ring.com knowles
in some ways when you're trying to think
about inflation and foreign policy and
the war in ukraine and immigration it's
so complicated but in other ways it's
really simple
when you live in fantasy things go wrong
whether you're talking about the border
whether you're talking about foreign
policy
yes we're just going to we're going to
take all the sanctions off putin and but
we're going to give him a stern warning
and say hey don't invade ukraine we're
going to take out all the incentives not
to invade ukraine but we're going to say
hey
invade you don't invade ukraine
we're going to take off all the
disincentives to crossing the border
illegally we're this is what happens
you get
chaos you get madness
do you think
this is i know i'm preaching to the
choir here but i want to ask this of
liberals
do you think we like being the bad guy
and saying no no you have to work
no you can't just sit at home for two
years and expect the economy to remain
the same no we can't just print money so
that you have more money in your wallet
because it's actually not going to
increase your wealth no not everyone can
come to america we're only going to take
3 million a year not 4 million people a
year
no you can't change your your sex no you
can't append every do you do you think
we want to do that no we want to be the
nice guys and we want to be able to say
hey do whatever you want and no sit at
home sit on the couch if you want and
hey we're just going to print you money
but it doesn't work that way because we
live in reality and there are
constraints
and when you when you don't accept the
fundamental facts of reality
men are not women people have to work to
make a living
bad guys are going to want to expand
their influence and we've got to smack
them on the hand and tell them no when
you don't accept the basic facts of
reality things go awry
that's the world that we're living in
and so the biden administration
refuses to accept reality and puts his
head in the sand on domestic policy on
foreign policy and everything in between
and things have gone wrong so now
the best thing that they can do is
distract from everything
and and focus on the one political win
that they've had
during the entire administration and
that is the confirmation of katanji
jackson to the supreme court which jen
saki is going on all the news shows to
trot out to say was the most historic
wonderful life-changing joyous event in
history and and everyone was crying
tears of joy because they got this judge
on the court
it was as you know dana from working on
these in the past it it was a very
emotional day in the white house a
joyful day and there's so many days in
the white house no matter who you work
for that are exhausting and
heartbreaking and challenging because
there aren't easy answers to heart
problems sometimes but this was an
incredibly joyful day a day we
celebrated a day many of us were ugly
crying on the white house south lawn
just celebrating this remarkable woman
who is making history but she is also so
qualified to serve on the supreme court
you were ugly crying on the south lawn
because some federal judge got a
promotion
you were ugly crying meaning not only
had you lost control of yourself and
frankly i wanted to cry when katanchi
jackson got nominated but i didn't
because i'm an adult with some sense of
uh responsibility and decorum not only
were you crying
you were ugly crying you were shaking
you were you were streaming tears
everywhere because
some judge got a promotion
you it's not as though the republicans
have the majority in the senate it's not
as though this was particularly hard
it was easy biden just picked a lady and
then there were short confirmation
hearings the republicans didn't put up a
fight at all the only people to put up
any fight on it were cruz hawley and tom
cotton
no the entire rest of the gop and the
conservative movement just rolled over
and then she gets her
promotion and then you were why
why there's nothing
remarkable about that and they're
pretending that this is some some
historic win for the oppressed people
she's not the first black person on the
court she's the third and she's not the
first woman on the court
the
the current black person on the court
before katanji jackson
is
elevated
is clarence thomas who the libs hate
and the one there are multiple women on
the court first woman on the court was
appointed by ronald reagan so none of
that is historic
i don't think that it's worth ugly
crying over even if it were
but but i i suppose it just underlies
the problem these are not serious people
who are not in control of themselves who
are emotionally stunted children running
our show that that is who we've got and
and so biden is doing his best to make a
big deal out of the easy confirmation
process of katanji jackson because it's
the only thing he can claim a win on and
now
to try to rile up his base he's going
for some tried and true red meat he's
pushing gun control
from the very beginning the second
amendment didn't say you can own any gun
you want as big as you want you couldn't
buy a cannon when in fact the second
amendment passed
and certain people from the very
beginning weren't allowed to purchase
guns
it's nothing new it's just rational
so biden wants to take your guns he
wants to push gun control he thinks this
might help him with his base in the
midterms but just on the
on the
statement that he made it's not true you
could buy a cannon at the start of our
country
you could buy a cannon lots of people
bought cannons and there was no rule
against that
so as
as per usual
the premises that joe biden and the
democrats are pushing are not true and
if you start with bad premises you're
going to end up with a bad conclusion
which is joe biden wants to take all of
our guns forget about cannons he wants
to take our most basic rifles away from
us
garbage in garbage out in
the physical world and in logic and in
politics why is he doing this what what
this gun control push says to me is
biden has not tried to
win the midterms he's not trying to win
over people in the middle and centrists
joe biden is trying to stop the bleeding
by riling up his democrat base
with inflation going crazy now more than
ever is a great time to look into alto
ira right now go to
a dot altoira.com slash michael
you know we predict the future on this
show well we told you months ago if
you're investing if you're investing in
crypto do it in a tax advantaged way
with alto crypto ira
well i i hope you took my advice on it
then because inflation is going through
the roof the value of our dollar is
plummeting if you haven't done it it's
not too late even if you're dabbling in
crypto don't just pay needless money to
the government in taxes go do this in a
tax advantaged way the best way to do
that is altos crypto ira will save you
the tax headache you can trade all that
you want you can get started by
investing with as little as 10 and there
are no setup fees there are 80 coins of
it more than 80 coins available actually
we're talking bitcoin we're talking
ethereum we're talking cardano
do you want some sushi swap with your
bitcoin well you can do that no problem
alto ira has you covered open an alto
crypto ira account with as little as 10
bucks go to alto ira.com michael
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
m-i-c-h-a-e-l start investing in
cryptocurrency today altoira.com
michael biden's gun control push
is the clearest evidence that i have
today
that he he's given up on
on winning over moderates and winning
over center right people the squishes
who
who are at least somewhat open to joe
biden and the independents he's given up
on that joe biden is just trying to stop
the bleeding by picking up a big bucket
of nice bloody red meat and throwing it
out to his base and making a bunch of
stupid statements like you couldn't buy
a cannon at the time of the american
revolution and we what do you need a gun
for why do you need to have a magazine
with 10 or 20 rounds that you don't need
that to hunt deer why would you ever
want that come on man and just a bunch
of idiocy
because it's the best shot that he's got
and i don't think
that's going to do it
i don't think even his base is depressed
he's underwater on every single issue
other than the confirmation of this
judge which is a win for him this week
and maybe next week but it's not going
to last through november it's not going
to get these guys through the midterms
and if if inflation continues to go
through the roof the number they've just
released the number jen's hockey
yesterday set the stage and said we're
warning it's it's an extraordinary
elevated number it's 8.5 percent eight
prices are up 8.5
that is insane
it's a new 40-year high we're gonna have
another 40-year high next week
it's
the inflation rate has exceeded
economists predictions it's exceeded
even what the democrats were setting the
stage for at the white house and it's
going to drive these people from office
if we have fair elections
so right on cue when we're when we're
wondering if the elections are going to
be fairer this time and we're going to
follow the rules and we're not going to
upend all the election rules like we did
before 2020
enters dr fauci to say actually folks
kovid's not gone yet haha i'm back
well obviously there is concern that we
are seeing an uptick in cases as i've
mentioned over the last couple of weeks
john that this is not unexpected that
you're going to see an uptick when you
pull back
on the mitigation methods if you look at
the cdc calculation with their new
metrics it's clear that most of the
country even though we're seeing an
uptick is still in that green zone which
means that masking
is not recommended in the sense of not
required on indoor
settings but as people pull back when
you have a highly
transmissible virus like the ba2 and you
have pulling back on mitigation methods
at the same time there's waning immunity
we're going to see an uptick so the
numbers you gave
are not surprising but the idea that
we're going to see an uptick i think
people need to appreciate that that's
the case and follow the cdc guidelines
because remember
when the metrics were put forth the new
metrics looking at the guidance of
masking it was said that if we do start
seeing an uptick particularly of
hospitalizations we may need to revert
back to me being more careful and having
more utilizations of masks in door
where is my hat where is my nostradamus
hat and my crystal ball i don't even
need it to make my predictions you know
i hate to say i told you so i told you
so
i told you this was going to happen a
month ago everyone was saying oh michael
kovid's over don't worry you know we
have that three-part docu-series on dr
fauci it came out what about a month ago
i think it is the most watched content
we've ever put out for daily wire
members you can go check that out today
at dailywire.com without you unmasked
but one of the criticisms at the time
people said oh michael wow i really like
the docu-series but fauci he's old news
kovid it's over it's going away i said
it's not going away
it's not joe biden did not withdraw the
national emergency authorization
they have not withdrawn the mask mandate
throughout the country actually
what we've just found out today is some
cities are bringing the mass mandate
back
the mass mandate is still in place in
new york for instance for little kids
the mass mandate is still on the planes
the airplanes refuse to get rid of it
they're telling us maybe this month i'll
believe it when i see it
they're not getting rid of it
one because the democrats want to keep
power centralized in the bureaucracy
they took a lot of power during covid
and they don't want to give it back
that's not how power works it's not how
politics works but two kovid is their
biggest excuse to cheat in the elections
i hope our oligarchs at big tech don't
take me down for saying that but it's
obviously the case
the
the election whatever you think of the
results of the 2020 election was by far
the most rigged election we've had in my
lifetime
they changed all the rules beforehand
and they used covet as the excuse to do
it and they pushed for these widespread
mail-in ballots which are rife for abuse
which even barack obama not all that
many years ago admitted were not a good
way to conduct elections because they
were vulnerable to abuse in some cases
it was in violation of the state
constitutions like in pennsylvania
and they're going to try to do it again
they're going to stuff the ballot box
this is nothing new
democrats have been particularly guilty
of this over the years but republicans
have cheated in elections too ever since
there have been elections there has been
cheating and so sometimes the conditions
for cheating are
stricter and sometimes they're more
relaxed
and so they're they're holding on to
code that i think
i think that this whole covid stuff
might have a little bit more to do with
politics than it does with the science i
know that's a shocking suggestion but if
you don't understand that now two years
in you're not going to make it you're
not going to understand that
that is one of the ways the democrats
have cheated the new york times is
already setting the stage they said get
ready for the latest wave of covet okay
i'm i'm going to get ready at the end of
october something tells me that's going
to be when kovit really strikes back
that was one of the ways they cheated
but the other way they cheated is
through big tech i was talking about the
oligarchs who control speech in our
republic well what does tech do
tech censors
articles and information that is
critical of that are critical of
democrats there was the obviously the
hunter biden story right before the 2020
election republicans broke news about a
laptop a hard drive of hunter bidens
that was found with lots of evidence of
crime not just from biden's derelict son
but implicating joe biden as well not
just weird sex stuff not just weird
drugs but also financial crimes that are
coming out more and more and more and
now
18 months later we're finally hearing
the new york times and washington post
admit that that is the case 15 percent
of voters said that 15 of biden voters
said that had they known
that that was the case that there was
this laptop that had implicated him in
some crimes they would not have voted
for biden could have swung the election
so
it's why this issue of big tech is so
important it's why it should be if not
priority number one at least in the top
three for republicans and it's why we're
all so happy that elon musk is now
taking over twitter
we like it not because elon is some rock
ribbed right wing conservative
but because he's certainly not woke he's
certainly not with the left
and he has gone in and he's bought nine
percent of twitter more than nine
percent of twitter
and he was offered a seat on the board
of directors
initially he was going to accept this
seat
then we got some news that that elon
musk is not going to take the seat on
the twitter board of directors the first
reaction from conservatives to this was
disappointment we were crestfallen oh no
we were so close to changing twitter we
were so close to taking back the public
square oh no why won't elon musk do it
now that some information is coming out
as to perhaps why elon musk didn't take
the board seat the reaction has been
elation so this from perag agrawal who's
the ceo of twitter
elon musk has decided not to join our
board we announced on tuesday that elon
would be appointed to the board
contingent on a background check and
formal acceptance elon's appointment to
the board was to become official
effective uh april 9th but elon shared
that same morning that he will no longer
be joining the
board okay
no further explanation but this is how
aggraval signs off the letter the
decisions uh there will be distractions
ahead but our goals and priorities
remain unchanged the decisions we make
and how we execute is in our hands no
one else's let's tune out the noise and
stay focused on the work in what we're
building
what do you mean there are going to be
distractions what do you mean it's going
to be a bumpy road ahead what are you
referring to
your main antagonist elon musk just said
he's not going to join the board
well here's what's in the contract that
they initially gave to elon musk
said mr musk will agree that
for so long as mr musk is serving on the
board and for 90 days thereafter mr musk
will not either alone or as a member of
a group become the beneficial owner of
more than 14.9
of the company's common stock
outstanding at such time including for
these purposes economic exposure through
derivative security swaps or hedging
transactions
so the deal was we'll give you a seat on
the board if you agree not to up your
stake in twitter right now you own nine
percent nine and change well you can't
own fifteen percent or more if you join
the board but one board seat isn't
actually that powerful so more and more
it looks as though twitter offered musk
the board seat not to give him a seat at
the table but to actually rein in the
power because he's gone in and he's now
the single largest shareholder in
twitter it's not that easy
to buy nine percent of a company like
twitter
it's not like elon just picks up the
phone he says bye bye bye sell sell sell
no this is a complicated process
he's doing it because he wants to
influence the company and what this says
to me
is that what this says to me is that
elon musk
is not interested in pulling back from
this whole twitter game
it says to me that he's interested in
taking it on much more potentially a
hostile takeover here which would be one
of the most important things we could do
in this country for free speech in the
defense of the traditional american way
of life do it elon go on i'm reading the
tea leaves here i've got my nostradamus
hat on don't let me be wrong go in
hostile take over boot out these woke
idiots give us back our public square
that's that's what we're trying to do
over here at daily wire we're trying to
influence not just the political and
media landscape but we're trying to
we're trying to smack down corporations
all over the place a lot has happened
since our backstage well we've got
another backstage coming up that
backstage is going to be tomorrow we're
going to be talking about everything
we're going to be talking about biden's
disastrous presidency we're going to be
talking about the insane uptick in
inflation we're going to be talking
about corporations like disney do not
miss it it's going to be me ben jeremy
matt drew clavin tomorrow night 7 pm
eastern 6 p.m central over at
dailywire.com if you are not a member
yet go to dailywire.com use code build
the future and you will get drumroll
please
45 off yes four or five percent off if
we are going to take on massive
corporations like disney we need your
money it's as simple as that if you
don't want the discount code that's fine
don't use promo code build the future
just subscribe we could use the money
but but uh if you want to join us right
now we are offering this deal to show
you how serious we are about taking on
those what corporations we'll be right
back with a lot more
in elon musk's potential hostile
takeover of twitter he has two proposals
right off the top that he's pushing
we're not talking about the long coveted
edit button we're not even necessarily
talking about restoring banned accounts
like the trump account or others
we're talking about well for instance um
turning the twitter headquarters into a
homeless shelter elon musk is suggesting
especially because
the twitter employees don't actually
show up for work
because they're still remote because
they're neurotic and and are afraid of
of kovid and they want to live in a
world without germs that there's no
reason to have this expensive real
estate here and you can turn the twitter
headquarters into a homeless shelter
elon suggested this people thought it
was a joke and then he said i'm very
serious about this he might do it do it
i love it he follows this up he says
we're thinking about changing the name
should we remove the w
should we remove the w from twitter
would that improve the company i think
it would i think everything musk is
doing right now is exactly the right way
to handle this
which is troll them into the ground
troll this company until
it is ash until you bring them to heal
and bring them into submission
or destroy the company entirely but but
what we're talking about here is
the difference between a friendly
influencing of twitter and a hostile
takeover when elon first bought nine
percent of the company you saw these
nice happy tweets between the ceo and
elon hey we're ha ha we're so glad
elon's joining please don't fire us and
elon oh yes i can't wait to work with
all of you that was the nice friendly
version that broke down within what 72
hours
now we're in potential hostile takeover
territory that's the only place we're
going to be
the left
will only respect strength
in many ways it's like we talk about
foreign policy
they
the only thing that these guys who hate
us who think we're racist and sexist and
this is and phobic and terrible and
we're killing kids and we're murderers
and we're a threat to public safety
the only thing they're going to respect
is political strength
bring them to heal take over the company
take out the w make a mockery of them
fire them make them quit make them run
away you're seeing this not just here
but you're seeing this with the florida
law after the florida education bill
you have teachers in kindergarten first
grade second grade who are very
frustrated because they want to trans
the kids and bad boy desantis won't let
them trans the kids and so they say well
we're going to leave we're going to quit
we can't do our job
great sounds good to me problem solved
don't let the door hit you on the way
out love that personnel is policy
get these guys out of here do you
remember when the army posted that woke
ad that recruitment ad when i was a kid
the army ads were be
all that you can be an army of one and
people climbing up mountains and doing
cool manly things well now the new army
recruitment ad is a woman saying that
she learned how to how to be a soldier
when her lesbian mothers took her to a
pride parade and put a rainbow on her
face the the cia now is recruiting and
saying that the cia loves woke la tinx
intersectional feminist whatever the
hell and part of the reason that they're
doing that
is to get the conservatives out they
don't want the conservatives they want
the woke people
they the conservatives had
one or two institutions left in the
entire country the military and
am radio i guess where that's like sort
of like one and a half and the left
wouldn't even let us have that a lot of
the the
heavy-handed enforcement of the covet
rules a lot of that has the benefit for
the left of getting the conservatives
out of these institutions
we've got to do the same you're seeing
it in florida you're seeing it
potentially in twitter great stuff we've
also figured out by the way why disney
has gone so insanely woke
because i couldn't figure it out i
thought
yes all the corporations are going woke
now but why is disney in particular
disney where the bread and butter of
this company is families as kids is
normal people it's not even the woke
crazy coastal elites it's normal people
in the middle of the country who for
whatever reason decide to spend
thousands and thousands of dollars going
to a theme park in florida or california
where they can wait for seven hours to
go on two rides i don't get it it's not
my thing but a lot of people love it and
the people who love it are normal people
they're not radical ideologues so
why are you going to flip them off why
are you going to have your company now
say
you can't engage with our product
because we're going to trans your kid
we're going to steep them in radical
ideology what was the thought process
well now we've got a little bit of of
information on it the disney heiress
charlie disney has just come out as
transsexual
this woman
who's a woman but who thinks that she's
a man is a high school teacher she
critic criticized the florida parental
rights and education law
saying these children the gay children
and the transgender children and the
pansexual and all these
the children that she believes have this
extraordinarily firm sexual ideology and
identity she says they can't learn about
their community and their history at
school
or play sports
or use the bathroom that they want to
use
yeah that's true
at least the last part of that is true
the last two parts yes the little boys
can't use the girls bathroom
i hope actually now they probably can in
lots of places but they shouldn't be
able to
it's disordered and weird for little
boys to go use the girls room at school
and the heiress to disney who's got
disney right there in her name is crying
about this
she says i haven't told people this
before but i'm a transgender and i've
always known and this woman's mother
apparently told the los angeles times
that from the age of two onward
charlie
was pulling away from the girl's shoe
section at the department store and
saying but mom i'm a boy on the inside
so i in a way i sort of feel bad for
this woman she's a grown woman now
charlie disney but her mother's
obviously a complete lunatic too who
believes that a two-year-old can pick
her own sex
and so she was raised in this it's a
very personal issue for her and it's
probably the biggest challenge
conservatives have on this transgender
issue on sexual issues generally is
people take it really really personally
and so you can sit them down over a nice
cup of tea and say listen i've got
charts i've got graphs i've got a white
board behind me
boys
not girls and you can speak in the most
elementary simple logical terms that you
can and that's probably not going to get
through because people are going to
interpret that as an attack on their
identity the left loves this the left
has always tried to make politics
personal this was the slogan of the
second wave feminists in the 1970s they
said the personal is the political
if we make our personal lives
right down to who does the dishes
right down to who cooks dinner if we
make that a big political issue open to
public scrutiny and if we make public
political issues extremely personal and
say that if you oppose a radical
political agenda you're a hateful
terrible monster who wants to kill me
if we can do that it's going to be much
easier to get our radical agenda through
the conservatives aren't going to know
what hit them and they're going to have
a harder time arguing against it because
our political agenda will be immune to
facts and logic
that's what they're after and they've
done a pretty good job of this
what the libs are saying
right now is that if you don't want to
lop off the genitals of a five-year-old
if you don't want to put
little little kids in elementary school
on cross-sex hormones
that you are killing them the suggestion
that you would mutilate the genitals of
a little child
would have been preposterous even three
four years ago even on the radical left
today
the idea that you wouldn't do that
the idea that that if you oppose that
you're a terrible murderer that is being
pushed by the white house
to be clear every major medical
association agrees that gender affirming
health care for transgender kids is a
best practice and potentially
life-saving
gender affirming health care by the way
means the opposite of what it sounds
like it's an ironic phrase because
really gender affirming health care
would be when you tell a confused boy
that he's a boy
i know you're confused i know you're
having problems but i'm affirming you
the reality here you're a boy and they
use the phrase to mean
delusion affirming health care
and where they say you're
you think you're a boy but you're
actually a girl we're gonna lock your
genitals off and she says look all the
experts all the all the major experts
say that this is a best practice and so
we're going to do it but there's a
little trick to this it's not just the
expert doctors i would be skeptical of
them if you're not skeptical of guys
wearing lab coats after the last two
years i can't help you you're not going
to make it but there's a little bit of a
difference here she doesn't say it's all
the top doctors all the top scientists
she says it's all the top associations
meaning it's all the top political
entities
that represent people in lab coats and
represent the pharmaceutical industry
for instance and represent the people
who are going to make a lot of money on
this and already are
we we covered this on the show last week
the big study that the libs are citing
on how lopping off kids genitals and
putting on them on cross-sex hormones is
really good for them and makes them feel
happier that study is funded by an
organization that is funded by the
pharmaceutical companies that stand to
make the most money from pumping the
kids full of hormones and putting them
through these horrible procedures you
think that's a little bit of a conflict
of interest i think so
she says you have to do that it's the
best practice
it's not the best practice
it's a horrible crime and people who do
it should be jailed okay
first they should be sat down and talked
to and said don't do that don't trans
the kids and if they insist on doing it
they should be thrown in prison it's a
horrible horrible abuse
and so the left says we have to do it
it's a best practice but then on the
other hand they say but it's not
happening by the way
on the other hand they say it's not real
none of this none of these conversations
are happening in k through
second grade or third grade like you see
in the florida law every time i've
talked to a liberal about this on the
show or off the show that's the first
line of argument they say it's not
happening
the law is
is taking on a problem that's not real
well we have evidence libs of tick tock
one of our favorite accounts on twitter
has video of a first grade teacher
indoctrinating kids
in kindergarten through second grade
classrooms into transgenderism
so something that's really cool and
unique about who i am is that i am
transgender
so we touched a little bit about that at
the beginning of this week uh in the
book that miss hammond read but i'm
gonna give you my explanation about what
it means to be transgender as well so
when babies are born the doctor looks at
them and they make a guess about whether
the baby is a boy or a girl based on
what they look like and most of the time
that guess is 100 correct there are no
issues whatsoever
and but sometimes the doctor is wrong
the doctor makes an incorrect guess
when the doctor makes a correct test
that's when a person is called cisgender
when a doctor's guess is wrong that's
when they are transgender so
i'm a man but when i was a baby the
doctors told my parents i was a girl
and so my parents gave me a name that
girls typically have and bought me
clothes that girls typically wear
and until i was 18 years old
everyone thought i was a girl and this
was super super uncomfortable for me
because i knew that wasn't right
this is all obviously abusive this is
very confusing for children it's harming
their education
this girl i get i guess he's a woman
she's a woman it's very confusing she
says i was born a woman but now i'm a
man
or i was born a man but the doctors made
their best guess and then thought that i
was a woman because i've got all the
female body parts and i'm obviously a
woman so this woman is extremely
confused and should not be allowed
within a hundred yards of
of children and should certainly not be
teaching any children
the issue here is that nothing she said
is true
she is spouting delusional madness
when you walk past derelicts on the
street who are on drugs or who have all
sorts of mental problems and they're
just spouting nonsense and they're
talking to the air and they they are
talking to the multiple personalities
floating around them that that only they
can see that you can't see those people
make more sense than this woman
it's just completely wrong
it's especially wrong to confuse little
kids like this especially over an issue
that could have such horrible effects on
them they could end up mutilating
themselves they could end up
not knowing their very basic identity
and basic facts about the world
but it's just wrong it's not making
anyone happier
do you think that that woman is
stable happy
ready to go okay that's all i had to do
was pump myself full of hormones and
maybe undergo some
mutilations i don't know what and now
i'm really happy and well adjusted no of
course not and i
i don't really believe any statistics
that i read but such that we have
statistics none of this stuff is working
the argument from the the white house
and from the democrats right now is that
gender affirming counseling and drugs
and health care is really helping these
children deal with their stress and
anxiety it's not true you look at any
social scientific evidence the numbers
are getting worse since we began
indulging this crap five six seven years
ago
the rates of
suicide depression anxiety have gone up
they've especially gone up in kids
they've especially gone up in kids who
consider themselves lgbt lmnop so
whatever we're doing it's not working
it's having the opposite effect
and what are we doing the strategy is
affirm the delusions
and what is the consequence i know that
correlation is not necessarily causation
but i think there might be a link here
when we indulge delusion when we live in
fantasy world everything gets worse
nothing gets
better
people are really struggling so what's
what's the answer
let's try something different let's try
maybe the opposite approach
and these people who are pushing these
extraordinarily harmful and destructive
and false ideologies
they need to be put away
from the first grade classroom they need
to be put away from positions of
influence they need to get better and
they need to be brought into accord with
reality it's i'm not just focusing on
this one issue of transgenderism which
is no longer can you even really call it
a minor issue because it's exploding
right now in the public square
it's catching on like a social contagion
i'm talking about so many other issues
people are getting more anxious more
stressed more lonely more miserable and
so whatever we're doing we need to turn
it around
there was
one of these viral tick tock videos
of a woman who's obviously very radical
on the left of the political spectrum
that just went viral
that really really tugged on my
heartstrings take a listen
guys i really need some friends
um
i'm a really cool person
and i know i look weird and i act funny
but i promise i'm cool
i'm really nice too
i have a car i'll bring you up
oh where's my gas on you
you can play with my dog
please be my friend
i'm so lonely
some people were making fun of this
video
that video broke my heart that is
actually a hard video to watch
and what's so hard about it is one this
woman is clearly in pain
but
two what's hard to watch about it is
that it's not extraordinary if this were
unique if this were just a one-off oh
this poor woman she's got these unique
singular problems i hope we can help her
that would be one thing the problem is
that it's not unique
the problem is that we're getting much
lonelier
this is a social problem and it's been
building not just for years but for
decades at this point
people are lonelier more isolated less
connected more stressed out more anxious
and the reasons for this run very deep
it's not easy enough to say oh well take
some drug
or oh just change the way you're
thinking read one self-help book and
you'll be better no this goes really
really deep
it goes it actually goes down to this
issue of delusion
people don't have friends anymore people
don't even understand what friendship is
anymore people think that friendship is
just
the
that going to brunch or something people
think that friendship is the people that
you spend a little time with and maybe
you kind of like some of the same things
or maybe you just met one another
through happenstance and you're friendly
enough and you you you have pleasant
enough conversation and therefore your
friends friendship is is much deeper
than that i think it was c.s lewis who
said if lovers or are people who look at
one another who are just totally
enraptured by one another friends are
people who stand next to one another and
look at the same thing
and they've got slightly they're pretty
pretty aligned on how they see that
thing but they've got slightly different
advantages because they're individuals
but they're looking at that same thing
and the crux of that matter is objective
reality
it's very
hard to have friends when you are stuck
in a solipsistic hell
it's very difficult to have friends
when you deny basic features of reality
because then you have no way to
communicate with other people then
you're not looking at the same thing or
you're at least not admitting to looking
at the same thing
then everything is about you you you and
your subjective feelings and your your
caprices and your whims and your
delusions and it traps you i'm i don't
mean to speak glib or flippantly about
any of this it's horrible when you
indulge your fantasies
you isolate yourself from the world
inevitably because no one can see the
things that you're imagining
and it's this is
i'm not just talking about a handful of
people with some psychological problems
or the larger number of people who have
caught on to that because of a social
contagion i'm talking about pretty much
everybody in the culture and now on the
rare occasions that people can have
friendships we sexualize everything
we have this line we'll say if you're
friends with a buddy you go out you're
like hey buddy hey man i love you man we
had a great this is great i really
enjoyed this conversation i really
enjoyed this thing that we've done
together or i just really love your
friendship hey man i love you no homo
and we say no homo because the
suggestion is that any time you have any
care for someone it's sexual
everything has become sexual which is
part of attraction it's part of human
connection but it's not everything there
are other kinds of loves as well
that entirely missing from our discourse
it's why you're seeing a decay of
friendship it's why you're seeing a
spike in loneliness it's why people
don't understand who they are
that
expect more videos like this
it's heartbreaking and no one has the
courage or the common decency to tell
people this woman has pronouns in her
bio and she says that she's a they so
she's obviously got some kind of trans
pan
multiple
genders i don't know she but she's got
those those kinds of issues in
particular and it's symptomatic of a
larger problem
now
if our politicians
don't take on that issue which is not so
simple as fix the gas prices fix the
immigration system go
hit putin on the head it's a little bit
deeper it's a little more cultural and
social it's not so simple as hey leave
me alone just don't you do you live your
life just don't raise my taxes don't
infringe on my rights we're talking
about reconstructing
the family we're talking about
reconstructing civil society we're
talking about how we all get along
together in politics if a politician is
not offering you answers there then the
politician isn't offering you much of
anything at all desantis has a great
a great gut on this desantis just signed
a bill in florida
to promote
fatherhood
this is a 70 million dollar bill he is
spending hard-earned taxpayer dollars
to beef up the american family and
specifically to promote fatherhood
one of the worst social trends has been
the decline of fatherhood and we do have
in many instances a fatherhood crisis in
this country
the fact of the matter is
when you take kids that do not have a
father present during their upbringing
the chance of them dropping out of
school uh getting involved in trouble
with the law having other difficulties
increases we've got community groups and
non-profits that want to be there to
help and so we're putting our money
where our mouth is we're here showing
the importance of this but you've got to
be willing uh to do the right thing and
be present in your child's life
it's not you're not a man by leaving
your kids
hung out to dry you need to be there it
is response it takes a lot of
responsibility it's not easy it takes a
lot of time and effort
but that is what we are called upon to
do
and we want to make sure that every
single kid in florida
has
that has their father present and if we
can do that
i think it's going to be huge
for the vitality of our communities
absolutely it will be whenever i see
some angry leftists shrieking with crazy
colored hair and all sorts of
mutilations just screaming and saying
all sorts of vile things i will often
joke with my friends they'll joke to me
or i'll joke to them say hey that person
probably has a great relationship with
her father right
no probably yeah there's obviously they
got a great relationship i have a friend
of mine who says that all left-wing
politics basically amounts to screw you
dad
this will show you and i'm i'm joking
about it it's kind of funny when some
angry leftist is doing that
but it's it's quite sad
actually and it's especially sad when
people are showing you that the misery
that they're living in
a lot of which comes from broken
families and not recognizing our own
place in the family in society in the
country in our relationship to our maker
that is
a fundamental political problem that we
need to use the government that we need
to use our political resources to solve
and if we don't solve that kind of thing
and we just continue to live in atomized
isolated fantasy the no amount of tax
cuts or or administrative regulations is
going to do a damn thing to make the
country better i'm michael knowles is
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show teen
depression and suicidal ideation is up
there a bunch of reasons why the white
house warns of catastrophic inflation
numbers and kamala harris didn't wear a
mask at a public event because you know
she has feelings that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen